[Music]
foreign
well he was caught up in a missile alert
while visiting the McLeod region and he
saw Holmes destroyed by bombing raids
and visited children recovering from
life-changing injuries in hospital and
delighted say that he joins me now on
the sofa
um and Dom just a taste of what you were
experiencing then you're just saying
you've had your first proper really good
night's sleep I did yeah it's one of the
weird things when I mean one of the
things I didn't realize when you go into
that sort of area is technology has
moved on so you know before you go to
Ukraine you'll recommended you download
an app it's called air alert a Ukraine
you put in the places you're going to
and then anytime something takes off
from uh somewhere or a missile is
launched this app goes off telling you
to go to the shelter then you have the
air alerts going off and then as they
know where whatever's coming in is going
they kind of narrow it down but it does
make for very
uh fitful night's sleep you know because
you're constantly being woken up and it
is a kind of Terror tactic in a sense
because it's just keeping people
constantly on edge and of course you
have the luxury of going in coming out
100 I mean I was there three days and it
was stressful but I mean there's nothing
but the eye it's that prolonged just
permanent state of slight anxiety and
nerves that must be just unbearable
especially for kids well what is life
like for the kids out there I think one
of the things that I found really weird
about the Ukraine is that a lot of it is
very normal I mean you know I grew up in
Lebanon there's an excite I know what
it's like in a war that people do try
and keep going and try and have some
sort of normal life and it's
interspersed with stuff happening and so
sometimes when you go you think well
there's not a war on I mean these cities
are going on fine but it really affects
the kids more than anything else because
the one thing that's really stopped is
education so schools have been bombed
you can't open a school now unless it
has a bomb shelter which none of them
had and they've got broken windows and
they've got stuff that's not working so
a lot of kids in Ukraine now are
spending a lot of time Underground in
bunkers they're doing all their
education online they've been dispersed
around the country if not out of the
country and they re the the puff of
Education they just don't have a social
life they're not being allowed to be
kids and so we I followed want to save
the children's mobile digital Learning
Centers and they go out to sort of
remote Villages near the front line and
basically at least give the kids twice a
week some sort of uh class but really
it's more that they can just have a
social life and be kids and act together
and that's important when we learned it
here in this country with covert didn't
we though
be together it really affects their
resilience that's one of the real
ironies of Ukraine is that they've just
been through covid and they've sort of
got used to learning online and just as
that's coming to an end this started so
it's just been you know that's a really
long period in someone's childhood to
live that kind of existence and you
mentioned growing up in Beirut I mean
how did that compare I mean obviously
technology you know and all of that has
changed massively hasn't it so you know
their experience of childhood living in
a in a war zone quite different from
yours yeah I was trying to think of the
the differences I mean we did have
shelters and the Lebanese are very kind
of because it went on for so long uh
there was a little bit of life goes on
so I remember going to school and then
there'd be an air raid or shells would
land and we'd all go into a shelter and
wait till it was over and then come back
out and carry on with the class
um stuff did just carry on in Lebanon
but I think what I I mean I certainly
wasn't you know I wasn't I we were
shelled and I did live through a war I
found it incredibly stressful and
anxious when I came over here and I
think looking back
I don't know if I had PTSD or whatever
but I certainly was affected by it and
and back then there's nothing I mean no
one talks to you about that it's just
like stiff upper lip carry on and I
think one of the great things that
really sort of gives me hope is is when
you go and see these kids who are
clearly stressed I mean I met kids that
had been you know on a railway station
and being hit by shells where 60 people
were killed and others that had fled
from Mario poem they I mean they've
really had stressful stuff and at least
there is a place and say the children
organize kind of uh people that they can
talk to and at least try and talk
through what's going on and that's so
important
what do you think did you learn anything
from the experience in obviously seeing
it firsthand but you've been to Ukraine
before yeah I have been to Ukraine
before I I just learned
it's just such an extraordinary conflict
because it's so massive and it's it
seems to have sort of ground to a to a
halt it's almost like a first world war
situation where people are taking you
know 100 meters of land and then losing
it again so it seems to be in a sort of
limbo and that as I said does allow
people in the big cities to kind of have
a normalish life but the kids are the
ones that are really affected by it and
that's what I really realized you can
see the longer it goes on the more
effect it has on on the children which
is also storing up problems for the
future of the country as well massively
in every way yeah because I mean this is
a whole generation that have now been
pretty much online living dispersed from
their friends having families broken up
and being incredibly stressed for over
four years now
so you put this documentary together
what are you hoping it's going to
achieve I suppose because I'm an
ambassador for save the children I I
like lots of people think well what are
these Charities doing what what what's
actually happening on the ground and I
was as eager to see as anyone else is so
really they just gave me the opportunity
to go and see all the different things
that they do from giving people cash
grants we met a family that um they were
living right on the front line and the
Villager was on the front line and they
left after about four days of fighting
the next day their house was completely
destroyed by a bomb finally they've
managed to move back now the front lines
moved but they had no money they both
lost their jobs so say the children were
able to give them a cash Grant straight
away just to help them get back on their
feet while they were living with
relatives I met training centers where
teachers were being taught how to teach
online I mean there's so much stuff
going on on the ground and it's so
helpful and I met people that were just
so grateful literally coming up and
saying can you thank people in Britain
certainly for people who'd put up uh
people who've gone out there well
Thanksgiving of what they've done so it
was it was amazing actually
well it's really great if you're coming
to talk to